after my accident I see things
differently I see life from a whole new
perspective Kevin Hart's got a new lease
on life following his near-fatal car
accident in September some of the
craziest things that happen to you end
up being the things that you needed most
the 40 year old comedian spoke out for
the first time since being involved in
the terrible car crash that left his
spine fractured in three places while
his friend was driving his 1970 Plymouth
Barracuda in the LA neighborhood of
Calabasas Kevin shared an emotional
video on Instagram updating fans on his
health and how long his recovery process
will be okay he's doing fine he's doing
fine it's as far as I know from the last
I heard he's fine from a weight training
to pool workouts
Kevin gave fans a glimpse into how he is
regaining his strength after the blow to
his body and major surgery I understand
what it takes to get hit and that's a
lot of hard work dedication and I'm at a
point where I don't plan on slowing down
anytime soon
things have definitely changed since
Kevin made that statement in 2016 I
honestly feel like God basically told me
to sit down no you move it too fast
you're doing too much sometimes you
can't see the things that you're meant
to see a source told ET earlier this
month Hart is not planning to go back to
work full-time until the first of next
year so don't take today for granted
because tomorrow's not promised more
importantly I'm thankful for God thank
you for life I'm thankful assembly still
being here
the road to being a bigger and better
version of me
before it's an amazing 22
[Music]